With my editor open, I'm just going to create a new folder for this.
You can put the material wherever you'd like but for this purpose I'm just going to create
a new material folder here and hit materials.
So all I've done here is right clicked on the content folder, new folder and it's created
a materials folder.
Alternatively, I can also in the root just right click new folder as well if you prefer
to take that approach.
So inside my materials folder on the bottom left here, I want to create a new material.
So I'm just going to right click in this empty space at the bottom.
So right click material and I use the naming convention m underscore and then whatever
the material is.
So let's just call this rock.
So m underscore rock is my naming convention.
Some people put mat underscore for material.
Whatever you'd prefer, again from the outset we were talking about good naming conventions
and being consistent with naming conventions.
I think just pick a naming convention that works for you or your team and then just keep
that consistent.
So I've just hit enter there and it's opened my material.
If you didn't have, again just open my content drawer by pressing control and space bar.
If I didn't have this material selected already, I can double click it as well to open it.
So we see the material editor and the slide that we're referring to before and this is
the basic outline.
So the first thing we'll do is we'll hold the number 3 key down and left click and that
will create a vector 3.
So holding down 3 on your keyboard and left clicking will create a vector 3 and I'm just
going to plug this into base color.
I'm going to click on the constant value on the left hand side.
So constant, this black box and we'll just give it a color, whatever color you like.
I'm going to create a purple rock today or a pinkish rock shall we say.
I'm just going to save that.
It's always good to just save as you go.
Just keep working as you're iterating and I'll also change the property here just so
I can see my material a little bit better.
So I'm going to set it on the preview mesh here and then using the exact same editor
viewport navigation that I was using before, so right mouse drag goes in and out, left
mouse drag pans around and both zooms in and out.
So in case you want to do that.
So you can toggle the different view modes if need be and just make sure if it goes invisible
that you're not right next to it.
So next I'm going to hold down 1 and left click to create a numerical vector here and
I'm going to plug that into metallic and I'm going to press 1 again, hold that down and
I'm going to plug into roughness.
So I'm just holding down 1, left mouse clicking to create these values.
Now you'll see my color here.
I'm going to right click on the color and convert this to a parameter and I'll call
this rock color and I spell color the British way, apologies for that and I'm just going
to move that into location.
I'm just left mouse dragging and holding these into position.
So left mouse click and hold down to move them into position.
I'm going to right click this next metallic one and you can probably guess what's going
to happen next.
I'm going to convert to a parameter and go to metallic and we all spell that the same
way and then the same thing again.
So I'm going to right click on roughness, convert to a parameter, call that roughness.
Now I'll save again just to make sure everything's lined up and I think what I'll
do is I'll change the roughness metallic value by default.
So metallic value we mentioned is either 0 or 1 in the previous slide.
So let's go to the default value here and let's just hit 1 for now and you'll see that
it changes to a more metallic looking material.
So just to show you the before and after, 0 and 1.
So we've got a much more metal looking surface which we probably don't want for rock but
I'll just show you in this example anyway.
Maybe it's a precious type of rock.
And then roughness, let's put the roughness value at 0.5.
Somewhere in the middle gives us a bit more roughness.
So you can see as the roughness is dialing up it looks, it still looks metallic but it's
got a rougher surface so it's not as shiny which is probably what we want for an unpolished
rock anyway.
So we've got rock color, we've got metallic and we've got roughness.
Now I can close this and if I open my content browser by hitting control and space bar,
I might actually apply this to a surface here.
So if you've just got a default surface in your scene, if you've created just an empty
scene you could go to your shapes tab and drag and drop in a cube maybe if you wanted
to drag and drop a cube in.
We've got some basic geometry in the place actors here.
So shapes, cubes, sphere, whatever you want to do.
I'm going to press control and space bar and I'm going to get the rock material, I'm going
to drag and drop it.
And you'll be able to see we've got this material inside the editor here.
You'll see it preparing shaders on the bottom right hand side here and that's just figuring
out how it's rendering this object.
You can also see that there's a materials section here whenever you select a mesh.
Now I could have quite equally if I just clear out this value by resetting this value, you
don't need to do this but it goes back to its default value.
I can make sure I select rock in my content browser, go back to select this and just plug
it in using this and it assigns it as well.
So whether you drag and drop or you assign it here, it's completely up to you.
Maybe if you're assigning it here we can go back and add it to the favorites at the
top, that would also be okay.
But for now I think that's fine.
The power now comes in material instances.
So we've got our main material which is our parent material, we've not really defined
it as parent, it's just inherently a parent because it's a material.
Now let's create a child from this parent.
So I'm going to right click the rock and go to create material instance.
So I'm going to create material instance and you can go with the naming convention
that gives you.
So it goes m underscore rock underscore inst or you could rename it.
I sometimes go mi rock underscore o1 for example.
So mi for material instance, rock for the rock and then o1 because I might be creating
multiple of these.
Now if you want to rename something you can hit F2 with it selected or right click rename
as well if you wanted to rename it from its default value.
I'm going to double click the material instance now and we'll see that this is a condensed
version of the material editor.
We can see our material here.
We don't have the node graph but what we do have are these vector and scalar parameter
values that we added previously through the rock color, the metal and the roughness.
So we can actually tick the rock color, tick the roughness, tick the metallic.
Well actually let's not tick the metallic for example because we know metallic either
wants to be one or zero and I don't think I'm going to edit this.
I think I'm going to leave all my material instances at one as metallic.
So I don't, I mean you can leave it ticked to never change it but I'm just for demonstration
purposes I won't tick metallic just because we're not going to edit that.
So let's go to rock color and maybe we found instead of an amethyst style rock maybe we
found a different, maybe you get rubies or whatever color you feel like going to and
hit OK.
And maybe I ramp that roughness up to make it more rough and I'll save that.
I'm going to close it and maybe I duplicate this object by holding down Alt on my keyboard
and left mouse dragging.
Alternatively I could drag and drop another cube in but just to get familiar with these
shortcuts it might be worth doing.
So I'm going to open my content drawer again.
I've got my rock here.
Maybe I'll drag and drop it onto this object and you'll see that now I've got two different
color of rocks and the power now comes.
I can just right click duplicate and it goes to rock 02.
It automatically names it the next one.
I'm going to double click this.
Maybe I'm going to click the color.
Maybe I'll go to blue.
Maybe I'll hit OK.
Maybe I'll change the roughness to zero and it's a really shiny rock.
I'm going to save it, close it and duplicate holding Alt and left mouse drag and you can
see that I've got my rock selected there.
Maybe this time I'll just plug it in through here.
So again I'm just trying to move faster now just so you can see that once you've got that
base material set up you can start working very quickly and very efficiently using these
material instances and the reason why the material instances have these editable properties
if I go back into my main rock is because we created these scalar parameters.
So again just a reminder I held down one and left clicked and by default it hasn't got
anything.
So I'm going to right click, convert it to a parameter which then allows you to give
it a name.
This name doesn't have to be roughness.
That roughness doesn't need to align.
If I called this roughness value for example and press save I wouldn't even need to call
it roughness value.
I could call it anything I wanted.
I could call it zebra if I wanted and if I double click the material instance you can
see roughness value now.
So the name doesn't have to correlate with the actual thing that you're editing.
It's more just so you know exactly what you're editing.
So hopefully that gives you a good idea about materials and material instances and then
the power that you can get out of them by instancing and changing the properties per
instance.